Casey is with us and San Diego hey Casey
how are you good how are you did better
than I deserve what's up I am a recent
graduate I just graduated graduate
school I'm going to have a lot of
student debt so I was just wondering
what was your opinion on the how quickly
I could pay back this orange debt burden
what's your graduate degree in nursing
you got a master's in nursing yeah I'm a
nurse practitioner a nurse practitioner
okay good and so have you landed a
position as a nurse practitioner yeah my
income growth before taxes is going to
be $100,000 okay good and you're used to
living on nothing because you were broke
college student 20 minutes ago right
great how much student loan debt do you
have two hundred and nine thousand
dollars
Wow yeah yeah okay so I use big numbers
here all right two hundred and nine
thousand divided by three would be 70
thousand a year if you want to be done
in three years and that would put you on
beans and rice rice and beans with
absolutely no life and all your new
doctor friends are gonna think you're
crazy but their own broke by the way
nothing more broke on a doctor do you
think that's doable even after the taxes
come out probably not it's probably
going to take you a little more than
three years but the other thing is you
can probably pick up some ER time and
you probably pick up some side gigs
because what you've got you've gotten a
degree in a wonderful field that's in
high demand as you know probably and so
I would hope during the next three years
that not only can you pick up some side
gigs some he our time or whatever but in
addition that your income will just
increase that you're just starting in
100 that by the end of three years you
might be making 130 right right yes sir
when we add all the bat in
I'm just kind of putting your income on
a curve not on a static line and I'm
expecting you to work like a crazy
person because you didn't get anything
else to do right now you gotta get out
of debt yeah buying anything okay yeah
your bro I just heard listening to you
yeah before I start listening to you I
did lease a car so is there any way I
could get out of the lease now sell it
okay now you have to here's how you do
it you have to find out what the car is
worth versus what the early buyout is
which is the equivalent of your payoff
call and ask them what their only buyout
is and then get you a beater because
you're your aberlin you're a brokenness
practitioner yeah feels like you answer
for medical field and you make six
figures but the problem is you have this
deep hole that you're in yeah I agree
yeah I was very excited getting a large
salary and then I kind of realized it
doesn't really mean anything if not yet
you're on you're gonna be okay but you
need to really you have paid a price to
get here in terms of your academics and
in terms of your study habits and the
length of time you've been in school
longer than most and all that so you
know how you know how to pay a price to
win you know how to delay pleasure to
get a greater result and that's what I'm
saying see if you come let's visit the
three year from now you how old are you
right now
I'm 25 okay let's visit you at 28 right
now and let's visit you make lets visit
you making a hundred and forty hundred
and thirty thousand dollars a year with
no payments in the world yeah see that
set you up the bone I set you up to
build wealth very very quickly and that
is worth sacrificing to be that girl
yeah okay and that's what I want you to
do that's what I would tell you to do
that's what I would have you do is don't
live like a doctor live like a broke
college student because that's really
what you are right now and so it's just
real easy to go celebrate you know the
the graduation and the new job with more
debt which is what you did with a car
but we have a probably have to reverse
that situation if you can if you can
figure out a way to get out of it and
that's what you need to do